three seconds left guys okay ready to go
I might go go the game launches on
December first and for the rainbow 6
siege team and players this is only the
beginning the game will continue to
evolve with new content throughout the
year eight new operators will be created
each new operator is a true game changer
their gadgets and weapons will make
every match a unique fight there will
also be free maps new modes ongoing
challenges and community focused events
and tournaments and that's year one nope
a wall no community split just a year of
free content now let's talk about the
season pets it's our VIP experience
you'll get one week early access to the
eighth game changing operators one week
before everyone else and they instantly
unlock plus you'll receive an exclusive
season pass skin a permanent renowned
boost that will get you what you want
faster the animal inspired safari bundle
for all of your weapons and extra daily
challenges to earn even more renowned
the development team is dedicated to
making rainbow 6 siege incredible for
years to come
Rainbow six siege
you